finally they arrived the first
passengers to freedom relieved to be
going home after two weeks coronavirus
quarantine on a cruise ship in Japan
happily he confirms his health is good
Hasmik glad officials greet the slow
trickle who tested negative and are
cleared to leave before they're whisked
away from the ship some described as a
floating prison where the corona virus
infection rate keeps on rising the
ship's quarantine didn't work it look
like a quarantine but it was nonsense it
didn't stop the spread of the virus it
was all over the ship some passengers
that's enough hundreds of passengers
including Britons still cannot escape
waiting for evacuation fearing infection
for many on board today there's still
nothing to celebrate and watching others
leave only adds to their misery they're
still waiting for their test results and
until they get the all-clear they're not
going anywhere
more than 600 passengers have now tested
positive for coronavirus the highest
concentration outside China
the Japanese government says it's taken
thorough action to prevent the virus
spreading including using masks
disinfectant in keeping people apart but
an infectious disease expert who's
worked with the bowler and SARS has been
on board and is seriously concerned I
was so scared of getting carbon 19
because there was no way to tell where
the virus is no green zone no red song
everywhere could have virus and
everybody was not careful Abadi they
take this seriously even these papers
that I wrote they're all going into a
zip lock in isolation in a Japanese
hospital I speak to coronavirus patient
Gerry like many of the recently diagnose
passengers removed from the ship she has
no symptoms
a silent carrier contagious without even
knowing I I'm hardly ever sick but I
mean I think I might have had a cold
that's worse than this I'm experiencing
no physical illness at all none with
passengers including Britons still
unclear when they'll leave the focus is
on getting people home but with another
79 testing positive today huge questions
remain about how a quarantine ship
became a coronavirus breeding ground
shiva Robins Sky News Japan